I get to a step to cap get more
comfortable with basically sort of basic
things I want to say that I gotta go you
know I can think there's like 10
different ways to say kill some kind of
simple word that idea I can't say it I
want to be able to maximize my time or
destiny yeah there's nothing to study
some things are going to be more
effective and being able to Adam
converse with real Italian so I still
want to keep the more than motivation
because I'll go to some things even
listen to enough sometimes because I'd
already get motivated are you deaf it's
more than it's easier for me to just go
so yeah you have any hints about trying
to make that step to kind of simplify
but keep keep the motivation out well I
think one of the things is like safe
here you feeling tallying but certainly
if you're learning spanish or english
for if you want to english or french
that I mean if you're looking at fantic
resources to read in the language you
want to counter the language did you
want to pick a book that's written in
the in the in the language like the
Spanish the book is written is from a
country where the Spanish do you want to
learn is spoken so you're going to Spain
and you're reading reading books written
in Spanish you want to read them by
spanish writer because they're going to
use words in that text that you're more
likely to encounter whereas if you learn
you know spanish say from Mexico they're
gonna be different words there so the
ones that you're learning are
necessarily one's going to be more
useful to you if you're going to spank
this you don't saying that and so if you
were looking at newspaper articles no
magazines anything like that you want to
get them from the place that you're
going to because that's going to keep
those words for familia to be the ones
you're more likely to encounter another
thing you can do is when I was mentioned
before with the dictionary and circling
the words that you're learning the
dictionary hold the language within
itself but it doesn't make any
differentiation between which languages
award which words are more frequently
used as opposed to other ones you that's
what you want to me shout in your
dictionary so by the words that you hear
and you learn if you mark them in your
dictionary you can start to see in a
glass
which ones are going to be more valuable
to you on a daily basis and so you're
not spending time learning things that
that aren't very useful to you I mean
you might learn a word and you might say
that your people my lap oh that was
using the 60s right but you've created
an experience for you but you also
create a memorable experience for it so
even if you're using the wrong word or
it was you know it's it's it's out of
date night or whatever the other person
is going to tell you the word that you
want to know and so that's that's not a
negative situation it can actually be
quite a positive one so I mean by doing
those things you're going to start
slowly started to chisel down to kind of
your your core kind of vocabulary you
can use technology to to find out those
those words as well but it's really you
know figure out what you're going to use
most often as vocabulary and make
yourself aware of it so then when you
hear you can then start to add those
things and stunt case of memorizing you
don't memorize the whole dictionary you
know what I mean you want to you want to
use you want to bring words into your
vocabulary and use them I'm as the Sun
trying to find out yeah source to do
that or something it's not sure but I'll
tell you what we did and what I did I
was where you work you are I had lots of
books at home in Spanish and Swedish and
all the different languages that I was
trying to improve in and I consider
using the dictionary tremendously
inefficient I don't use conventional
dictionaries because it takes so long to
find the word and no sooner have you
closed the dictionary that you have
forgotten what it was the dictionary
said so after a while I just got tired
of doing it if every so often you make
lists but then you never look at the
list so it's just very inefficient so
what what now what I now do is that you
know I read it's not as much fun but
I'll read it once on the computer within
our system hey we always have audio and
be anywhere they don't know I click I
got it and I save it and I got the
phrase and what our system does it
captures all phrases within our library
and including the stuff that you have on
your work desk that has that word in it
so you know I've got ten examples very
often from stuff that you've been
listening to where that word is used the
other thing we do in our system is based
on our library we assign a frequency
level
words so it's either a four-star word or
a three-star word or two star wars or
one story so you're going to be more
motivated coloring the four-star words
and in fact we collect those and we call
these knee or your priority woods and
every day you come in you flash card
those 25 priority words and when you
move them to a known category new ones
come in so you're always and when you go
to write the 25 high priority words pop
up there so we are constantly working
off the high priority words the other
thing that we do we remark yeah and and
when you are reading any word that you
have previously saved in the system is
going to be highlighted in yellow so
that when you bring in a new text you
start to see the words that you tried to
say before you forgotten that you can
save them are you forgotten that you
ever looked them up and using but if
they keep on coming up they're important
if they never come up again don't worry
about them so there are a number of ways
like that because I was where you are
but the fundamental thing is however
difficult it is an inefficient it is to
look things up in the dictionary if you
like those comments if you're more
motivated to live to read those comments
stay with comics stay with it because
the number one thing is the amount of
time you spend with the language so
whatever you do if you're motivated to
do it that keeps you at the language
reading listening writing speaking
whatever you don't do